I think you could characterize our
operating model as a stubbornness
and stupidity we were too stubborn to
quit now we're making more
audiocassettes than we've ever made and
that's something to say in 2015
national audio company began strictly as
a blank medium supplier
it wasn't until late in the 1990s in the
early 2000s when the many of the other
large duplicators the sight of the gold
and 2-cd replication that we realized
the audio cassette wasn't done we're not
in the music market when that happened
we were not hurt by it
our spoken word customers our blank tape
customers went right on that was the
floor under us that's the beginning of
our buying out our competitors
collecting all of their equipment
restoring it to new condition and
preparing ourselves to pick the music
market up when it came back that's
exactly what's happened the best part of
working with Steve is he is the king of
analog that man knows audio cassettes we
intend to be the last percent company
operating and right now we are the last
percent company operating this is audio
cassette duplication these are electro
sound slaves built in the 1970s
duplication is putting a sound on the
tape while the tape is being duplicated
Nichelle's show that in their imprinted
and their shells and the duplicated cake
needs at the loading machines this is
our cassette loading department these
machines take the tubs of faith and load
the men's of the audio cassette in each
machine they make 2,000 or more
cassettes in a day the part of the
machine you see here was billed as a
cigarette wrapper in 1938 it marries a
1938 mechanical machine with a
microprocessor another secret to success
at national audience
my job is to keep these running to the
best of my ability which is always a
challenge when you're dealing with
orphans the companies are long gone we
have 40 or 50 more of the duplicator
slaves from which we use parts when we
need them I'm working to train someone
else how to do this stuff but to try and
find someone that actually understands
tuning up of a magnetic tape recorder
probably the thing that has really
enlarged our business and a faster pace
than anything is the return of music to
audio cassettes the retro movement
there's the nostalgia of holding the
audio cassette in your hand we have an
amazing clientele we have a lot of small
bands we did the guardians of the galaxy
cassette from the movies soundtrack here
is the Metallica tape that we did there
is the under 35 age group who have
learned now life is not comprised with
mp3s and earbuds they like the sound of
analog and that has really helped us a
lot there was a drive from the
independent bands to get that warm
analog sound again and it just continued
to grow and grow
I do not own an iPod or an mp3 player
and I have a flip cover cell phone my
wife calls me in the and earth all